I saw Mad Max when was that last summer
and it absolutely melted my mind it was
such a stunning movie and I'm so glad
that it's getting the recognition it
deserves at these award shows that's so
cool you can and it's never expected it
to be honest
you didn't expect it well well I thought
we were done way back last year but
people are still talking about it so but
for a filmmaker that's it that's great
it's incredible I was just listing the
credits babe happy feet and the Mad Max
franchise how does that happen what kind
of mind do you have where you can switch
genres that way so effectively I I'm not
sure I'm not the person to ask but my
mom did say that she thought after the
babe and Happy Feet that I was coming
down and then she sold Mad Max fury road
and said George what's happening are you
doing these again yeah and and I figured
out was when I was young I make Mad Max
movies and then I had kids you have kids
mm-hmm and you stopped going out to
movies this spontaneously yes okay and
you're watching a lot of family movie so
that was sort of in my head and now my
kids are grown up I can go back to man
max really so your kids grow up and once
they're out of the house you can go back
to flamethrowers on dune buggy yeah well
they're sort of people dressed in S&M
outfit and you know with the it's Mad
Max has influenced the culture so much
you see it in so many ways and the
visuals in the latest film were stunning
we copied when we went to comic-con
we are cold open for the first episode
was us doing sort of a parody and I got
to be the doof warrior and II was
driving and that was I remember we will
show a quick clip for anyone that didn't
see it I got to be the guy in the front
of the truck
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I know he was perfectly safe the
whole time he knows what he's doing
you know it's but that where did you get
that idea because when I saw the film so
many people reacted to the doof warrior
the idea of here come the bad guys and
the lead the lead truck has a lead
guitarist suspended from a wire and he's
shooting flames from the neck of his
guitar where does that idea come from
well it's perfectly logical you it is
you okay it there's always the music of
war
you know the bugle of the drummer the
bagpipe player but in this case you've
got all those vehicles with v8 engines
and v16 engines and so on so it's very
noisy so the guitar and everything has
to have dual purpose and so a
flamethrower
yeah and the world to do a movie like
this everything has to kind of have an
internal logic then that even if the
audience doesn't understand what it is
they understand that the characters and
the people telling the story have their
version of it so for me it's for me it's
a documentary this is that's the most
disturbing thing I've ever heard you say
documentary of how our life is going to
be in about eight years 50 years it's
actually well goodnight kids even though
it's it in the future kind of goes back
to the past yeah which is a much more
kind of allegorical world a bit like the
westerns in fact the kind of westerns
only yes yeah hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography